estudió a 3 000 individuos en cargos de liderazgo ejecutivo
sobre la idea de cubrirse en el espacio de trabajo
con base en aspecto físico, apoyo, afiliación y asociación.
Al considerar el cubrirse según el aspecto físico
el estudio demostró
que el 67 % de las mujeres de color se cubren en el espacio de trabajo
debido a su apariencia.
Del total de respuestas que admitían cubrirse por motivos de apariencia
el 82 % consideraba que era desde bastante a muy importante
para poder avanzar profesionalmente.
Esta que ven ahora es Ursula Burns.
Es la primera mujer afroamericana en ser CEO de una empresa del Fortune 500.
De Xerox.
Se la reconoce por su aspecto distintivo,
el que pueden ver aquí.
Un afro corto, bien recortado y cuidado.
La señora Burns es lo que nos gusta llamar
una "chica natural".
Y está marcando el camino y demostrando
lo que es posible lograr para las mujeres afroamericanas que desean escalar
en la escala corporativa.
Y al mismo tiempo desean llevar cortes de pelo naturales.
Pero hoy en día la mayoría de mujeres afroamericanas
que seguimos viendo como líderes, iconos y modelos de conducta,
siguen optando por el pelo liso.
Tal vez sea porque lo quieran así.
Así es como de verdad se sienten mejor.
Pero tal vez...
Y apostaría a que sí.
Una parte de ellas siente que tenían que hacerlo
para llegar al éxito que han alcanzado hoy.
Hay un movimiento por el cabello natural que está arrasando en el país
y también en algunas zonas de Europa.
Millones de mujeres están explorando lo que significa volver al pelo natural
y cortándose años y años de puntas secas y dañadas
para recuperar la forma de su pelo natural.
Lo sé porque he sido defensora y embajadora de este movimiento
durante más o menos los últimos tres años.
Tras 27 años de calor excesivo y químicos agresivos
mi cabello empezaba a mostrar serios signos de deterioro.
Estaba quebradizo, y más fino.
Parecía extremadamente seco y frágil.
Todos esos años persiguiendo esa imagen convencional de belleza
que hemos visto antes
estaban empezando a pasar factura.
Quise hacer algo al respecto.
Empecé algo que llamé el "Desafío Sin Calor",
durante el que evitaría usar alisadores como planchas en mi pelo
durante seis meses.
Y como buena millenial,
lo documenté en redes sociales.
(Risas)
Documenté cómo me corté, a regañadientes,
unas tres o cuatro pulgadas de mi querido pelo.
Documenté cómo luchaba por dominar estos estilos de pelo naturales,
cómo me esforzaba por aceptarlos
y por pensar que me quedaban bien.
Documenté cómo la textura de mi pelo empezaba a cambiar poco a poco.
Al compartir de forma abierta este proceso
descubrí que no era la única mujer que estaba pasando por esto
y que de hecho hay miles y miles de mujeres más
que desean hacer lo mismo.
Me escribían y me preguntaban,
"Cheyenne, ¿cómo te hiciste ese peinado natural
con el que te vi el otro día?".
"¿Qué nuevos productos has empezado a usar
que puedan ser mejores para la textura de mi pelo
mientras empieza a cambiar?".
O, "¿cuáles son algunas de las rutinas capilares
que debería empezar a aplicar para reparar la salud de mi pelo?".
Pero también descubrí que había un gran número de mujeres
que no se atrevían a dar el primer paso.
Porque el miedo les paralizaba.
Miedo a lo desconocido.
¿Qué aspecto tendrían ahora?
¿Cómo se sentirían consigo mismas llevando un estilo de pelo natural?
Y lo que era más importante para ellas,
¿cómo las verían los demás?
Durante los últimos tres años
de numerosas conversaciones con amigas
así como con completas desconocidas de todos los rincones del mundo
he aprendido algunas cosas muy importantes
sobre cómo las mujeres afroamericanas se identifican con su cabello.
De modo que ahora al recordar
a esa gerente de contrataciones en Mobile, Alabama
diría "De hecho, no.
No sabemos qué es lo que quiere decir.
Pero he aquí unas cosas que sí sabemos".
Sabemos que cuando las mujeres negras aceptan su amor por su pelo natural,
eso les ayuda a reparar generaciones de adoctrinamiento
enseñando que lo negro en su estado natural no es bello
o que es algo que debe esconderse o cubrirse.
Sabemos que las mujeres negras expresan su individualidad
y se sienten empoderadas
al experimentar de manera frecuente con diferentes estilos de peinado.
Y también sabemos
que cuando se nos anima a llevar nuestro pelo natural en el trabajo
se refuerza que somos valorados como individuos únicos.
Lo cual nos ayuda a florecer y a avanzar profesionalmente.
Les dejaré con lo siguiente.
En una época de tensión social y racial,
sumarse a este movimiento
y otros similares
nos ayuda a alzarnos sobre los límites del status quo.
Cuando vean a una mujer con trenzas o una cortina de rizos sobre su espalda,
o noten que una compañera
ha dejado de alisarse el pelo para ir a trabajar,
no se limiten a acercarse y admirar
y a preguntarle si lo pueden tocar.
(Risas)
Aprécienla de veras.
Apláudanla.
Incluso choquen los cinco con ella si es lo que les apetece hacer.
Porque esto...
Esto es mucho más que un peinado.
Tiene que ver con el amor propio
y la autoestima.
Con tener el valor de no rendirse ante las expectativas de los demás.
Y saber que alejarse de la norma
no define quiénes somos
sino que revela quiénes somos.
Por último,
es más fácil ser valiente
cuando podemos contar con la compasión de los demás.
Así que a partir de hoy
espero que podamos contar con Uds.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)